we are here with the one and only molly
shannon
this is how we kick and we do it
you're so flexible i'm so flexible
you're a really good dancer really yeah
i remember i was like drew's a really
good dancer yeah really very good ski
i remember yeah i remember we are
animals and we got to get out of the
cage you're an animal you're an animal
but it's true i mean i do i feel like
i'm i do like that analogy of like the
greyhound at the gate we did this story
about this little like wrestling girl
who's taking on older boys and winning
whoa and like you should see her her
picture she's like
whoa and i'm like yes i love this girl
so much that's so cute it's so true i
think that it's life is
um
an opportunity to just
exactly and on that note
drew is my mentor because she was so
established in show business and when we
did never been kissed together
i had gotten my movie superstar green
lit and we were looking for directors
and so i had had a meeting with bruce
mccullough who we were pursuing to
direct superstar and i came back to drew
on set
and i said bruce mccullough passed on
the movie he's not going to do it and
drew was like what you can't let him
pass wait and i go no he he came into la
for a meeting he's flying back to
toronto and drew goes now wait a minute
you gotta call him back you gotta stop
his plane wait a minute she and you gave
me this advice i go well what should i
say you go ask him what his concerns are
ask him what he needs to make it work
does he want to work less days what's
the problem you know there has to be a
solution and just tell him you'll give
him whatever whatever he wants
don't let him get on a plane call him
and you
coach me and i wrote down what to say
and i called him and did exactly what
you told me and then he ended up taking
the job
[Applause]
what are we you talked about like not
like don't be beating things
oh
and you know listen you at a certain
point you got to take the no or you're
going to get a restraining order
yes
up until that point
you know until the law steps in or until
you know in your gut that you've pushed
too far and it's time to back off you go
to that line
what are we waiting for yeah and then at
least you tried even yet go for it
um now i want to talk about being busy i
love
if you have a new showtime show oh yeah
you're so hot off the other two and
white lotus and i'm glad it just never
ends and now you have this showtime show
i love that for you
yes can you tell us about that
absolutely so this is a show with
vanessa bear she's hilarious she created
the show with jeremy byler another snl
alum snl alum she's and she's also from
my hometown cleveland and so this is
about the world of home shopping network
which is such a fun world to be in and
my character's like the queen sales
person
and um vanessa's character comes in and
i take her under my wing and it's it's
really fun and the show's really good we
have a clip yeah yeah okay great
i can ask if someone else can train me
it's like insane that you would train me
you know what for you i'm gonna do it oh
i got a lot of great pointers and as you
know i'm really good at this
welcome to the jungle joanne
it's joanna oh joanna
and don't you dare take a picture of my
butt
[Music]
she's so funny
oh no you're the best oh everybody
if you want to read one of the most
profound beautiful books you will ever
read in your life
then you got to read hello molly and it
is available now in bookstores and
anywhere you get your books from and
then you can also catch uh molly and i
love that for you premiering april 29th
on show time i can't wait to watch that
show oh good watch every wild choice you
make and just thank you
[Applause]
[Music]